[Music]
we are finally learning what life is
like for Georgia and amals new twins and
what about Georgia's new role as a dad
well I found out today when I spoke with
his dad Nick Clooney have you seen a
change in George since the baby's
already since the word came out that he
was going to be a father no question
about a change really what is that
change a change is a and it has nothing
to do with age incidentally it is a
different kind of maturity George and
Amal FaceTime from the hospital with
Nick at just two hours after the twins
were born I looked at him they're
wonderful too I will tell you this also
there was very vocal
it says the babies are really vocal so
as George getting his movie star rest
you know I see the truth is I suspect
and I can't verify this yet on a
day-to-day basis I suspect he will not
get any standard rest until about
December 15 today et confirmed that the
Clooney twins little Ella and Alexander
were born in the same hospital as the
Royals was it an easy labor did they say
how the hell difficult it was how long
it was I've been told never to refer to
any labor as easy we've learned Amala
gave birth here in saga exclusive Lindo
wing at st. Mary's Hospital and is not
just where Prince George and Princess
William and Prince Harry it's discreet
it's secure it's private royal expert
Victoria arbiter says the hospital
offers hotel-like service the Clooney's
reported to have booked three rooms one
for a mile and the babies one for George
to be able to kick back and relax and
also to receive any guests that the
couple were welcoming and then another
room for their own private security
detail
you